[Aplausos]
[Música]
en 1991 tras varios años de tiras y
aflojas y mucha tensión los países
bálticos lituania letonia y estonia
lograron por fin romper con la unión
soviética de una vez por todas
alcanzaron la libertad
[Música]
habían pasado 50 largos años desde que
los soldados del ejército rojo okupas en
sus países durante todo ese tiempo la
represión y el miedo fueron los
ingredientes básicos en la vida de los
estonios letones y lituanos y es que
atentos a los datos tan sólo lituania un
país de poco más de dos millones y medio
de habitantes la ocupación soviética
dejó tras de sí estos números
[Música]
200.000 personas fueron arrestadas
interrogadas y encarceladas 132.000
deportadas especialmente a siberia y 75
mil prisioneros deportados y partisanos
fueron eliminados por el régimen
soviético
y por si fuese poco en el momento de su
independencia la miseria y la escasez
eran un ingrediente básico en el día a
día de todos sus habitantes recuerdo los
días en que los mostradores de las
tiendas de tallin estaban vacíos y la
gente estaba famélica la economía
prácticamente tuvo que reconstruirse
desde cero lo que se ha conseguido es
prácticamente milagroso si se mira desde
una perspectiva histórica desde entonces
amigos las cosas han cambiado mucho
muchísimo desde que estos países
recobraron la independencia apostaron
decididamente por la democracia y la
libertad
hoy sus economías se sitúan entre las
más libres del mundo son miembros de la
unión europea y de la otan cuentan con
niveles de vida bastante altos son muy
prósperos están saneados y a todas luces
ya los podemos considerar como países
ricos es decir el cambio de los llamados
tigres bálticos ha sido brutal incluso
cuando en 2009 sufrieron mucho la crisis
financiera internacional y sus economías
parecieron desmoronarse con caídas ojo
de hasta el 20 por ciento del pib frente
a todos los pronósticos en muy poco
tiempo en apenas unos años consiguieron
recuperarse y convertirse en todo un
ejemplo para países como españa grecia o
portugal pero de todo esto amigos
hablaremos en otro vídeo en este nos
vamos a ocupar de un grave problema
compartido por casi todos los países de
europa del este y que hoy por hoy supone
una de las amenazas más importantes para
su futuro
[Música]
'fuga de cerebros'
para conocer mejor los países bálticos
analizar de primera mano la
transformación que han tenido y también
los problemas a los que aún se enfrentan
especialmente en el caso de lituania
luego veréis porque he venido hasta aquí
y la verdad amigos os doy mi palabra de
que mi experiencia avala los datos el
cambio de estos países está siendo
sencillamente increíble
[Música]
la escena de lituania así como la de las
repúblicas bálticas en general es una
historia de éxito desde que en 1991
recobraron la libertad estos países se
han transformado muchísimo solo hay que
venir para verlo
hoy son países modernos con economías
prósperas y muy abiertos al comercio
bien hecho
[Música]
como en toda una historia no todo
siempre es bonito y si hay problemas
también en lituania en este caso el
problema es la fuga de cerebros la
emigración si emigración con él y ojo
que el problema no es precisamente
pequeño tan solo desde que el país
ingresó en la unión europea en 2004
lituania ha perdido más del 10 por
ciento de su población es decir más de
300 mil personas sobre todo jóvenes han
hecho las maletas y se han trasladado a
otro país por cierto casi la mitad de
todos ellos se han marchado al reino
unido
sí mientras que el nuevo accidental y en
eeuu hay un sentimiento de preocupación
por la inmigración
aquí en lituania es al revés están
bastante preocupados por la gente que se
marcha y es que aquí en lituania la
preocupación es que esto termine por
descapitalizar el país
[Música]
desde 1990 hemos perdido cerca de
800.000 personas y para un país pequeño
como lituania esto es una gran pérdida
estamos perdiendo a nuestra población
más joven y brillante así que en el
futuro sólo tendremos personas mayores
que morirán tendremos una sociedad
agonizante y como siempre entre los que
se marchan están los jóvenes con más
capacidades los mejores formados y por
supuesto esto tiene un efecto claro en
la economía la mano de obra más joven
disminuye el talento se escapa y la
población se envejece pero ojo porque
esto no es un problema sólo de lituania
es algo generalizado en europa del este
sólo un dato desde 1990 son ya 20
millones de personas las que han
decidido marcharse y quienes creéis que
son los ganadores de toda esta
redistribución del talento si así es los
países más ricos por eso hay que tener
mucho cuidado con determinados mensajes
que tratan de ganar votos convirtiendo a
la inmigración por sí misma en un
enemigo a batir si estamos pensando en
personajes como theresa mail o donald
pero se lo que estés pensando si los
bálticos han tenido tanto éxito porque
la gente se va pues precisamente por eso
por su éxito así como lo escucháis pues
bien por un lado estos países han
conseguido que en general la gente joven
esté bien formada y sepa hablar inglés
dos requisitos muy importantes a la hora
de buscar fortuna en otros lugares
por otro lado gracias al crecimiento que
han experimentado ahora tienen el dinero
para marcharse de una forma
relativamente cómoda
pero claro nos queda una pregunta clave
porque se marchan si aparentemente el
país va también pues no es difícil de
explicar aunque los salarios han
mejorado mucho en los últimos años la
diferencia con los países más ricos
sigue siendo bastante grande por ejemplo
mientras que el salario medio lituania
es de unos 800 euros en reino unidos de
casi dos mil quinientos euros tres veces
más y entonces qué está ocurriendo acaso
ha sido todo este proceso de
transformación negativo para el país
para nada siempre hay desajustes ahora
lo que deben preguntarse es qué supone
todo esto y cómo impedir esa fuga de
cerebros
para acabar con la emigración acabar con
los grandes flujos de emigración y
frenar la fuga de talento se ha
convertido en toda una prioridad en los
países de europa del este algunos como
polonia letonia o hungría han puesto en
marcha campañas de retorno con las que
tratan de convencer a los inmigrantes de
que vuelvan a casa me gustaría dar la
bienvenida a todos los polacos que están
en el extranjero si tan solo volviesen a
casa ese sería un gran día para polonia
sin embargo sin lugar a dudas es aquí en
lituania donde más preocupación está
generando esta fuga de cerebros y donde
mayor ha sido la reacción de la sociedad
i
[Música]
en las últimas elecciones parlamentarias
que se celebraron en octubre de 2016 un
peculiar partido conocido como la unión
de los campesinos y verdes lituanos que
sólo tenía un diputado de la legislatura
anterior fue el vencedor y se hizo con
el gobierno su principal promesa poner
fin a la sangría de la emigración
[Música]
pero claro amigos esto es algo que es
muy fácil de decir pero no parece tan
fácil de llevar a cabo así que la
pregunta es cómo quiere lograr semejante
meta a este peculiar partido que está
presidido por cierto por ramón as
karbovski uno de los empresarios más
importantes del país quien según dicen
su prioridad número uno para frenar la
emigración pasa por atraer mucha más
inversión extranjera según afirman si
consiguen que llegue a lituania mucho
más dinero del extranjero para invertir
lograrán que haya más empleos que
mejoren los tipos de trabajo y que suban
los salarios pero como quieren
conseguirlo para lograr atraer más
inversión extranjera el nuevo gobierno
ha prometido reducir la burocracia
perseguir fue realmente la corrupción e
introducir aún más flexibilidad en el
mercado laboral es decir aparentemente
parece que el nuevo gobierno no quiere
cambiar los ingredientes de la fórmula
de éxito báltica
la verdad todo esto suena bastante bien
tiene mucho sentido casi podríamos decir
que una vez más parece que los países
bálticos saben hacer muy bien las cosas
pero espera de un segundo aquí no acaba
toda la historia hay algunas cosas que
como decirlo no resultan tan bonitas
[Música]
las sombras de la apuesta lituana por un
lado al mismo tiempo que el gobierno
habla de inversión extranjera también se
ha comprometido a subir impuestos
eliminando lo que se conoce como flat
tax fijaos en lituania y también en
estonia y letonia los sistemas fiscales
son muy sencillos en el caso de lituania
existe un flat tax una tarifa plana de
impuestos tanto para empresas como para
personas del 15% es decir el que gana
diez mil euros paga 1500 y el que gana
10 veces más 100 mil euros paga también
10 veces más de impuestos en este caso
quince mil euros pues bien más allá de
otras cuestiones no aparece que la mejor
forma de atraer más inversión extranjera
y hacer subir los salarios sea elevar
los impuestos que por cierto para las
empresas no son tan bajos como parecen
si tenemos en cuenta los pagos a la
seguridad social y otras tasas e
impuestos según el banco mundial las
empresas en lituania pagan algo más del
40 por ciento de su beneficio bruto en
impuestos
por otro lado está el tema de rusia y la
otan los últimos gobiernos de lituania y
este no es una excepción se han empeñado
en trasladar a su población y también al
resto del mundo que hay una amenaza
cierta de invasión rusa que el país está
en peligro
vale es verdad lo hemos visto aquí en
visual político amenazas existen pero
creéis que esta es la mejor forma de
trasladar confianza a los inversores y
por último y tal vez lo más importante
una cuestión tal vez de corte cultural
que afecta a todo el país
si hay fuga de talento parecería lógico
tratar de suplir esta pérdida atrayendo
profesionales y jóvenes de otros países
no os parece sin embargo amigos también
aquí existe cierto recelo hacia la
inmigración los países bálticos son un
pelín nacionalistas en fin de todas
formas si algo está claro aquí es que
tanto lituania como estonia letonia han
hecho muy bien las cosas y que sus
políticas parecen bastante mejores que
las que abundan en el resto de europa en
apenas 25 años han conseguido
convertirse en países ricos con niveles
de vida bastante altos si no me creéis
os aconsejo un viaje por estos países os
prometo que además de disfrutar
muchísimo vais a sorprender os con todo
lo que han conseguido en tan poco tiempo
bueno y ahora turno para ti crees que
conseguirán las repúblicas bálticas
frenar esta ola emigratoria esperamos su
respuesta y como siempre
el vídeo no olvides darle al botón de
like un saludo y hasta la próxima o como
se dice aquí en lituania y keep us y
máximo
[Música]
[Aplausos]